all right so now I recently welcomed the
newest our programmer into my family he
was born almost on the 10th anniversary
of the New York our meetup so that made
me really really excited we missed it by
just a few days but you know you can't
be perfect
I want to thank Viviane pang and the
lander analytics team for making these
hex t-shirts because you'll see they are
baby themed hex t-shirts
Gigi poops probably my favorite and yes
these are true to life I've discovered
Messi are tiny verse yeah all the baby
spitting up all happens so what is in
the name we needed to pick a name for
this child and this is high stress
because this sticks them for the rest of
their lives you wanted to be a good name
you wanted to be not too common but not
too odd now for us it was a constrained
optimization problem we needed an L it's
a tradition to name your children after
to cease family members Sweden else
least we had it narrowed down there were
some very obvious choices that came up
right away Lando Lander I almost got
this my wife was a bit out of it after
labour and she signed a blank birth
certificate and I was really sitting
there like should I put in Lando
but then I've heard that the the court
system actually strike down names are
they're ridiculous so the next name I
really wanted which fit that we needed
an L was Lunar Lander
she also said no so we had to turn to
baby name books
it turns out Bruce Lansky has written a
lot of them but we're more digital so we
turned to tinder for baby names
[Laughter]
you literally swipe you and your partner
swipe through names and you both match
you get notified that you both like a
name
but then it dawned on me
how can I not use are anyone knows me
I've met my wife at the army and up our
has to be involved so I loaded up the
baby names package this is maintained by
Hadley and it tracks baby names in the
US since 1880
so I went into this I filtered on just
more recent names in 1980 and I looked
for boys and I saw I did accounting
based on the popularity in each year and
came up with an overall ranking since
1980 so I took that ranking and I made a
distribution so we just take the ones
that are greater than a certain
percentage and we make this histogram
this is a histogram of all of the
traditional boy names since 1980 with
the red line being the middle of the
pack it's a left skewed graph as you
would expect there's a lot of very
common names that a bunch of very
infrequent names but we needed an L we
needed an L name so remember that or an
L sounding name since L was a bit
constraining we've heard anything that
sounded like an L so I went back to my
query
I took the recent names but I also did a
regex in there for the names that either
started with an L or started with a
vowel then an L so we went through there
and there was about 587 names that fit
the criteria so we worked our way
through those 587 names and we narrowed
it down to two that we liked Eliot and
love so I wanted to see how these
stacked up with the rest of the
population so I made a histogram of just
the L names and see where they landed
and predictably Eliot is the 32nd most
common name in red and Lev is 175th most
common in blue and while they're both
good names for us I very quickly ruined
Elliot my wife couldn't handle a
lifetime of this
I was going to do it every day of his
life so leave one out it means heart and
when we're in the hospital it kept
sounding like love so my wife really
liked it so I won't with love so now
that we have his name the baby arrives
I'm like OMG we have a baby what do we
do we had no clue what we were doing at
all we barely managed to get him home
safely so fortunately though all babies
really do is eat poop and sleep right
that's the majority what they do and
they're often called a bundle of joy but
they're also a bundle of data we have
this app called hatch baby which lets
you record all their activities being
sleeping diapers and eating and you can
talk to Alexa to add items so you're
collecting all this data and then you
can export it to a CSV now you can see
the CSV it has all the pertinent
information but it's a little messy they
delineate sections with these three
equal signs begin feeding and feeding
it's a little messy and I try to figure
out why it was messy why would they
delineate the sections every single
column is the same in the whole data set
why they making these sections I thought
because Excel so we're going to read
that into our but first we need to clean
it up a little bit so we're going to use
the pipe function to call grep on the
file as it's being read into R and grep
- V means source - the opposite so I'm
searching for any lines that don't have
these three equal signs and those get
piped into R so it's a nice way of doing
pre-processing at the command line right
before you even read it in then we go
ahead we specify the column types
because there's a messy data we specify
the time zone because they didn't
include the time zone which leads to
problems and I restricted the data to
just be when he was sleeping or eating I
didn't do the diapers because I wanted
him to maintain some dignity
so once we get it into this nice format
we have to do some cleaning we had to
say what was going on clean it up we had
to fix them again fix more time zones
restrict the data to certain time
periods we had to deal the time zone
issue right here convert the duration
the durations they use weren't
necessarily great so we converted to
durations with based on some math and we
made it into a Sybil which is the new
version of time series data in R there's
so many versions of time series data
there's a new one from Rob Heineman
importantly we had to de doop the data
there were a lot of duplicate entries
because parents are tired notice my wife
about to pass out in the corner so we're
really exhausted but now that the data
is clean we want to see what was he
doing I want to figure out when was he
sleeping when was he not sleeping so we
took the data and calculated for every
minute of his life was he awake or was
he asleep you get it already and we also
converted the time into a factor and
there was about 300,000 minutes of his
life you take this data set which takes
a little bit of manipulation you pipe it
into a GG plot and we use genome tile to
make a heat map and then you get this
type of plot inspired by quilt I saw on
the internet like this the beige is when
he was awake the blue is when he was
sleeping and you can see it was very
erratic at the beginning then he
eventually stabilized and let us sleep
through the night because we were so
very lucky but you notice there's a
little blip right here as little blip
where he started getting a little weird
I was away at a conference in India and
Singapore and he got sick and kept
waking up my wife and I had a very
intact full response he missed me that's
why he kept waking up yeah and of course
he end up gangs take a few more times
getting us all sick too so I said you
know what babies also eat a lot so I
redid the code I had to make it a little
bit wider to make it just the table a
little bit different for different
plotting I went ahead and plot it as
eating on top of the sleeping in green
and you can see right here all those
green dots are when he was eating and
you can see
he ate a lot when he was really young as
he got a little older he started eating
a little more consistently a little more
quickly so things got a little bit
better so they thought well you know
let's fit some models on his sleeping
and eating so I go back to the data
start manipulating it again and for
every day of his life I calculated how
many minutes he spent sleeping and
eating the number of times he slept in
ate and the average amount of time he
spent sleeping and eating for every
single day so we take that and I also
calculated his monthly milestones every
time he gained a month in life to add to
the plot so we have those information
about his sleeping and eating habits his
timing and number of them in his Sybil
so since it's in a Sybil we could just
use auto plot and it makes a very nice
time series graph very quickly and
easily and we can see that his number of
naps and his number of eating's have
gone down over time he's doing less and
less in them of them similarly his time
spent has diverged so I guess not
similarly he has spent less time eating
and more time though we radically
sleeping and then we look at the
averages and we see yeah the average
time corresponds to what we expected to
see in the graph so now to fit a proper
model we create a training and test set
using filter index which is from the
Sybil package and allows you to take the
all symbols are filtered our index on a
variable see it knows what you were able
to use the dot means from the beginning
of the data tilde tilde till all of
September 2019 I didn't specify day I
said a month the test set was just all
of October or the days of October that
we had then we fit a model or models
using the model function with this one
function we fit seven models a mean
model a naive seasonal naive random walk
with drift and ETS and ARIMA and a
dynamic linear model with ARIMA errors
and that last model there we're trying
to see if I can see if I could see what
impact feeding has on sleeping so we fit
the models and then we forecast it
against the test data and get the rmsd
for accuracy and we see which models
perform best and
the dynamic linear model by a thin
margin and you can see that ETS did
surprisingly poorly it was the fifth
best model I was very surprised by that
but look how easy this is with Sybil and
fable and feast to get all this time
series information this came out about
two weeks ago or three weeks ago
it's really amazing what they did so
let's look at the models ETS was a
multiplicative model of an additive
trend and no seasonality the dynamic
linear model has a coefficient for
feeding and that negative coefficient
means that as he eats as he spends less
time eating he's sleeping more but
there's a very wide confidence interval
so maybe it's not worth the trouble
maybe we just go to a straight ARIMA one
one one model and this does it almost as
good of a job explaining his modeling
his patterns and with feasts and Sybil
and fable we can plot the forecast
against the true test data and see
what's happening and it's actually you
know it captures it fairly well it gives
you a nice confidence interval you know
it works but now that we've seen that
less detect change points also known as
regime changes and yes he was the regime
change in our lives so we need to prep
the data to do this we need to use pivot
longer which replaced gather and tidy
our to make into a long data set to do
our regime changes we are going to use
profit but we're not going to call
profit directly we are going to use a
package called fable dot profit to call
profit in the fable framework this way
you don't need to know how to use profit
which requires a y variable and a DS
variable this handles it all for you we
will then go ahead and get o in the
growth function says hey look for change
periods in these predetermined change
points see if there was a regime change
there we also got out the forecast from
this and we found out which change
points it detected were significant we
then go ahead and get the fitted values
from the training data and we get the
change points and there's a lot of pure
code I filed an issue on github to have
them integrate this into the functions
within the next day they had made the
changes but I had already written
my slide so I stuck with it so we plot
these change points for each of the
variables here and we can see there are
quite a few regime changes in his
patterns mostly falling on his monthly
milestones which you kind of expect
that's what all the baby books tell you
every month he'll have a change what I
really notice is that that the first
milestone for the feedings those changes
in how he was eating actually
correspondent very nicely to his first
pizza he grows he stares he loves his
pizza he's my son so nice thinking well
was there a difference in breast milk
versus formula so we go back to the data
because we were tracking it and we
assumed that if the number of ounces was
zero it was breast milk and if we had a
number of ounces it was formula in a
bottle so we take this data we go ahead
and we plot it like this with Auto plot
once again and we see it's a little bit
noisy and I prefer a bit of a smoothed
out time series so I'm gonna fit in a
Rhema model and plot the fitted values
from the Rhema model so it's a little
smoothed out I could have used
exponentially weighted moving average
but ARIMA model worked very nicely and
you can see right when my wife went back
to work we started changing patterns
here and eventually bottle-feeding
became the dominant source so after we
looked at all the types of feeding I was
like how long is he napping and I'm not
talking about sleeping overnight we
already looked at that his naps during
the day so we go back to the original
data we find when he started napping
after 7:00 a.m. before 6:00 p.m. we
numbered them and just looked at the
first three and we started in June gave
him a chance to stabilize to see what
was happening and then we go ahead that
since again this is a Sybil we plot it
and aside for a little blip in August
where the data went a little haywire
because I was in other time zones we see
it does look like he's sleeping more in
his first nap then I'm like let's see
this little
moved out over time I calculated the
average for each of the naps for each
month so we just do a index buy which is
sort of like group buy but a time series
equivalent and we plotted overtime for
each month and we really do see a trend
here that in the first in the first nap
of the day he is sleeping longer and
longer and the second and third naps
he's sleeping less and less and
sometimes he doesn't even take our third
naps which is really really awesome now
then I'm like let's just look at this
entirely overtime and see how he's going
just roll it all up and when we make box
plots there's a lot of variance and we
put ggb swarm over it to get a sense of
the distribution he is sleeping mostly
in his first nap right when his parents
don't need a nap also so thanks to the
contribution and you can see that his
second and third naps were also shorter
than the first one so we get a lot of
out of him so what do we learn from him
what are our key takeaways first he
really likes our t-shirts and yes I got
him a DCR hoodie from this conference
but his patterns are changing each month
as you know I'm sorry wrong one naming
things is hard much like off by one
errors you got to be careful naming him
his patterns are changing with each
month just as the baby book said they
would so people have been raising babies
for thousands of years they notice some
patterns his sleepy has gotten better
over time which has been amazing for the
parents it's really helped us out a lot
and his eating barely predicts his sleep
we thought we would really see something
about his sleeping patterns and eating
patterns going together it's a very
small marginal effect and he naps most
in the mornings which again is not
awesome for the parents and of course he
really loves pizza as evidenced by this
so thank you very much
[Applause]